something sherry has actually been
talking about we've been following lake
mead has had its lowest level since the
lake was created so that impacts farmers
water supply power generation it's why
vice president kamal harris is in the
valley today to promote the white
house's infrastructure proposals bianca
holmen live in the newsroom with more on
the vice president's visit bianca hey
good morning john good morning heather
the vice president will receive an
update on the conditions here in our
region the bureau of reclamation
national park services and the water
authority will share the latest on
drought conditions here so vice
president kamala harris will make a case
for the build back better agenda and the
bipartisan infrastructure bill she'll
share how the administration will
address issues like climate change the
impact of clean energy investments and
details about the water for tomorrow act
which is included in that infrastructure
bill now prior to her visit the
republican national committee will host
a press call to discuss the biden
administration's agenda and also local
representatives will be there to support
her adina titus susie lee steven
horsford they'll all join her on the
visit to lake bead bianca holman live
local now